I'm gonna say something right i text
this guy Bryan Callen
all right out of the blue he don't text
me back baby what did you text him I
said [ __ ] Richard flirty hahahahaha
who's he
well then he posted on Instagram about
he was going on and off about this guy
named Richard Flaherty he was a I guess
in the Vietnam War he was four foot nine
and he was like like a Purple Heart
winner or whatever do you win those are
what you earned those earned em you
can't win them no if you shoot 25 babies
or whatever or gonna mean you get you
win a Purple Heart no when it's the same
word sure okay alright so um but then
this flirty guy was for nine and he won
a bunch of medals he was also the green
beret but he was for nine and and Bryan
Callen was on Instagram getting really
emotional about this guy like this guy's
a hero and then later in life you know I
mean he had alcoholism and he died or
whatever it might be and I just texted
[ __ ] dead zone nothing
nothing from this guy and it's been you
know not even a Hello text me back look
at Ike Barinholtz i text them you good
nothing yeah but that's not a very if
someone texted me you good I'd like you
didn't put it too much thought they do
follow-up do a follow-up okay what do I
do
you're really good just not how are you
really good yeah yeah you know I think
that'd be a fun game you tell me who to
tax and you can you guys are allowed to
write me the tax okay I'll do without
meaning to do this because if you do it
that you're gonna put some extra [ __ ] in
there oh that's a point right no no no
so give me just give me somebody let me
talk to him that's not Andrew Santino
tell me what to text and I will text on
it nothing rude like you know me and
your mom's a rapist or anything like
that you know I mean yeah but it would
be [ __ ] Flaherty
yeah ooh trim the air arm
I'm really high I can't I'm sweating
alright keep it on are you to tell me
Andrew Santino let's start go ahead and
weird yeah yeah oh yeah let's go
something specific that Bobby wouldn't
know about like audio equipment yeah go
ahead
hey hey Andrew quick question
okay hey this is something that I would
never say and I'm gonna show ya Andrew
quick question you also have to
punctuate okay and I never got a quick
question quick question quick query
query how do you why alright by chance
would you happen to
weights one or it's a 1 R right yeah
query quick query per chance I'm a
chance to get perchance perchance
purchase perchance would you happen to
know which instance when I need okay
perchance would you hmm would you happen
to know which extension I need happen to
know would you happen to know what
extension which which know which yeah
which extension is that which like w ith
88 like which witc switcher which do you
happen to know which which extension
extension I need I need for the cloud
lifter okay yeah would good for the
cloud lifter any suggestions would be
appreciated we appreciate it would be
appreciate that it would be appreciated
thank you so much thank you so much in
advance thank you so much in advance
yeah yeah he literally is gonna call me
right away go what's wrong with you did
you fall on your head what's going on
with you Thanks what is it any
suggestions would be appreciated thank
you so much in advance
thanks so much in advance PS can I
borrow your USB 3.0 what no the PS is to
cache we want him to sound like a
[ __ ] let's just start there you want
me to sound like George
so here's ever done thanks in advance
when approved so here we go so this is
his yeah you can't see his number up
there yeah Oh what one time one time
D'Elia texted me once
mm-hmm and then I posted it on Twitter
but I didn't crop out his number above
[Laughter]
and then you still got a bunch of text
from like random people do you get a new
phone phone number I think you did yeah
oh so here we go and send so let's see
let's see if you'll give me somebody
else Eric Griffin let's just start here
what about David Spade Oh Oh see you're
not playing the game for real for real
or I'll play the game for real no Missy
really really enjoying you playing the
straight man on this one with this one
and then you're gonna teak about his
movie on his performance yep I
especially love the scene let's play
this game then I'll give you my phone
you can randomly text anybody anything
you want but I can do with you I have no
fears oh what's a challenge really I
have no fears I'm sweating so much
insane oh yeah I'm gonna give him a nice
critique of him you can't there's
certain people you can't tax especially
like someone like Marc Maron right now
oh do you not think I have no cheer what
yes she's got none G yeah don't go
what's that yeah anything like that when
people play the game a little later I
just have a sense I just you know what
it's such a nerve-racking thing you know
because if you were to go through my
phone who would you text first
I would probably text Gardo okay you're
[ __ ] with family this is a family
using a family because I know where
you're gonna go with that no I'm gonna
go hey I was just you know I'm not this
is why our text Cardone
hey you know it's not going well with me
and Bobby and I you know I just I'm
having feelings for you again it for
some reason like I miss you you know I
mean but I think it's more than friends
something like that oh my god he would
call your bluff so quickly he'll call
you know it's you that's all yes yes